the death of freddie gray in 2015 was a
flash point in the fight against police
brutality
that continues today gray died from
injuries he sustained in a baltimore
police van
protests erupted in baltimore and across
the country a new book
tells the story of what happened during
the most volatile days
through the eyes of eight people it's
called five days
the fiery reckoning of an american city
author wes moore is also the ceo of the
robin hood foundation
one of the nation's largest anti-poverty
non-profits
and he joins us first on cvs this
morning wes good morning
i want to start the
freddie gray's death was preceded the
year before by
eric garner's death and then the unrest
in ferguson after the michael
brown shooting they really kind of set
the table for what what's happening now
if you will
can can you talk about how you think the
protests after freddie gray's death
impacted what we're seeing today
i i think we're unfortunately we really
are reliving history
in many ways and where we're living
history because we've continued to allow
these tragedies to recede from our
collective memory without collective
action
and i think when we're when we watch the
images that we saw with freddie gray and
we think about what was different around
freddie gray because the truth is
in the two years prior to freddie gray
there was in baltimore alone
there was anthony anderson and chris
brown
and tyrone west so we watch these these
incidents happen
and then quickly recede from a
collective memory
i think what's happening right now is
there is a level of impatience
to any real seismic or systemic change
to dealing with these issues
that the frustration has now continued
to boil over and i think the
model that we're seeing from freddie
gray actually serves as an important
lesson
of what happens if these if this emotion
these actions
actually then aren't followed up by real
systemic change
you said the baltimore police force was
not the cause
of freddie gray's death but rather the
effect what do you mean
yeah what what what i mean is uh the the
history of of inequitable policing
is is as old as as this nation's history
i mean when we're talking about
uh you know the reality is is that uh
the sound of
police sirens uh it has a different
pitch
depending on what neighborhood that
you're in but when we're looking at what
happened to
freddie it's important that we deal with
the issues that caused his
his his untimely death it's important
that we deal with the issues of policing
reform it's important that we issue
that we deal with the issues of being
able to address what happened in his
death
but what i also mean it's important that
we understand what happened in his life
we have to understand the conditions
that existed
when you had a young man who was born
premature
underweight addicted to heroin
moved into a home after he gained enough
weight to
to to be able to leave the hospital his
mother never made it to high school
and then moved into a home that in 2009
that home
and 400 other homes were named
in a lawsuit because of the endemic
levels of lead
inside of this home so we now had a
young man who was born underweight
addicted to heroin lead poisoned and by
this time in his life he is two years
old
and so what i mean by that is we have to
deal
with the issue of policing but we also
have to understand
that it's not just enough to mourn his
death
we've got to mourn his life and we've
got to be able to put together systems
and structures
that can make sure that young men like
freddie actually have a chance
in our large society yeah you write that
that uh
in baltimore the odds started being
stacked against freddie
generations before he was born when you
look at what's happening right now wes
do you think something really is
different this time because as you say
we've watched this video so many times
now in the last five years
i think something is different and i
think the difference is is that the bar
is being raised
uh the bars being raised as the what we
identify as progress
you know one common misperception i
think about what happened in
in baltimore five years ago is there's
this idea that what what calmed
everything down
was when the national guard was called
in that's not true
the protests that were actually planned
on the saturday after
the uprising that took place in
baltimore were said to be as large
you know or larger than any of the
protests that we had seen thus far
what calmed everything down was when the
state's attorney actually decided to
press charges
against the six officers so there was
almost this euphoric feeling
in baltimore that justice might actually
be here
we actually might have people who are
accountable for the death
of of an unarmed black man that was able
to calm everything down
there was a consent decree that was put
inside of baltimore where the department
of justice
very clearly laid out the patterns and
practices
of systemic racism and injustice that
the police department was having on
black communities
here's the difference years later
no one was convicted for what happened
to freddie gray
a consent decree was rolled back and so
i think the bar is now risen
now what we're talking about right now
is not just simply about charges being
filed and consent decrees being filed
what we're talking about now
are laws being changed what we're
talking about now is
justice in every single form not just
justice in terms of policing
but justice in terms of economics
justice in terms of health so the bar is
now being risen
as to what progress is and i think
people are being very very clear about
that
yeah we should remind people that all of
the officers involved in
gray's case were either acquitted or had
the charges dropped against them
the baltimore police department told us
we continue to make
significant progress in implementing
comprehensive reforms
have they gone far enough wes
i i don't think that they would argue
that they've gone far enough yet uh
you know i think we we continue to watch
uh individual and smaller movements on
something that's a larger systemic
problem you know it's difficult for me
to have a conversation about good apples
versus bad apples when we have to reform
systems
um you know good apples and bad apples
don't exist when you still have systems
that need to be uprooted and i think
what ends up happening is you know we
have a lot of people who are
coming from a place of good will in this
we have a lot of people who are coming
from
you know a place a place of of of
sympathy and empathy towards what we're
seeing
but we cannot confuse or or or in any
way mistake
good deeds as being enough to deal with
larger injustices and it's unfair
it wasn't more than one of the reasons
why i wanted to follow these eight
characters
wes okay wes moore thank you so much for
being with us the book again is five
days it's on sale
june 23rd my birthday buy it we'll be
right back